everything is nominal we can they may
now be floating 400 kilometers above the
earth's surface however terrestrial
conflict has accompanied the
international space station's newest
visitors
first through the hatch is denise
mattvia hugs and smiles greeted sergey
kosakov denis medve and oleg artemyev as
they came through the hatch
but look at the colours on the russian
cosmonaut suits yellow and blue the same
as the ukrainian flag
it didn't take long for some back on
earth to conclude this was a coded
message of condemnation for their
country's invasion of ukraine
sometimes yellow is just yellow scoffed
russia's space agency on telegram but
russian mission control got on comms
just to make sure
that's their masking oleg why the crew
is wearing yellow suits while everyone
else on the iss wears grey here's alex's
reply
each crew picks the suits the overalls
out of their own choice so that we don't
all look the same
now it was our turn to pick the color
the truth is we'd accumulated a lot of
yellow material so we needed to use it
up that's why we had to wear yellow
flight suits
perhaps but russian space and defense
analyst pavel felgenhauer says if they
were making a political comment they'd
need a cover story for
a russian cosmonaut to go against the
great desert well i mean he'll be just
simply
not sent to space again and for them
that's a tragedy
and the russian cosmic agency and mitchu
regauzin have been absolutely supportive
of the campaign in ukraine so even if
they wanted to show kind of some kind of
resentment they found a very good we go
cover to say that this is just business
as usual
either way russia's invasion of ukraine
is putting huge strain on space
cooperation u.s sanctions are targeting
russia's space program the european
space agency is pulling out of a russian
european mission to mars
launches have been cancelled and
contracts broken years of collaboration
between russia the us and its western
allies are being pulled apart in weeks
rory challen's al jazeera